hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well justice is a term
which covers a lot of different bases
and can mean a lot of different things
raus in speaking of the prima facie duty
of justice wants to narrow it a bit so
that it doesn't bleed over into some of
the other duties like that of reparation
that have gratitude that a fidelity he
treats it as being what he calls a
general duty so that means a duty that
applies across the board for all of us
in relation to everybody else that
doesn't mean that there can't be certain
specific cases where the duty may be
reinforced by the relationship that we
have to other people so for example if I
have a previously existing relationship
with somebody they may they may think
that I have a stricter requirement to
make sure that they're getting their
fair share they ought to be I ought to
be looking out for them because we
already know each other so you know it
makes sense you know if I am the coach
of my kids little league team and what
we're talking about here in terms of
fairness is that people get to play a
certain amount
Arlis of how good or how bad they are
and then above and beyond that the good
players get to play more and you know
some people might say look you're
letting your kid play too much your kids
no good that would be unjust and they
would be rightly criticizing me for for
playing favorites in that case on the
other hand maybe I'm you know the other
extreme and I want to show how I'm not
you know being unfair to everybody so
even though my kid is great I don't like
him or her play as much and my kid could
come to me and say and what what's going
on dad how come you're treating me this
way I mean it's one thing for you to be
unfair to somebody over there
that's bad already but you're being
unfair to me and I'm your kid so these
these sorts of special relationships
specific relationships particular
relationships they can make the
obligation to to justice a bit more
stringent but in general it is something
that we owe to everybody what is justice
then so Ross says I don't want to get it
mixed up with say repaying your debts
that's part of the duties of fidelity if
I take out a loan I should pay back the
loan it is just in a certain sense that
I pay back the loan but not just in the
sense that Ross is talking about here
he says justice consists in this
bringing about a distribution so we're
allotting people different things of
Happyness all other people in proportion
to merit so what does that mean that
means when I'm dividing things up when
I'm assigning tasks when I'm divvying up
the income or the bonuses or cutting up
the the roast beef or pick whatever you
like when there's some sort of good that
can be shared among other people
I want to proportion that good that that
that happiness producing good in
proportion to what people
actually deserve there may be cases
where everybody deserves the same share
you know if I have five kids and all of
them are involved in different
activities should I say well you know
little Johnny I really like Johnny
better than the other kids so I'm going
to spend twice as much time on his
activities as a father as I will on the
other ones or maybe you know I don't
really like Susie and I like Johnny so
I'm going to take Susie share of
attention and I'm gonna totally deprive
her of it and give it to Johnny there
are cases you know where we say no look
you ought to be giving equal attention
to all of them and if you know you could
say well in this case I'm mistaken about
what counts as merit being somebody that
I like that's not something that merits
them getting more attention or less
attention or a bigger share of the
dinner or you know more scholarships or
less scholarships that's you know that's
actually to commit injustice to
privilege things like wow I happen to
like you and I don't like you we can
think about other things it would be
injustice of that sort to you no
discrimination on the basis of race or
gender or veteran status or religion
unless it's somehow relevant to the case
at hand you know probably everybody
should get the same sharon in that case
so there can be other cases where
justice says this person should get more
and this person should get less think
about grading for example I don't give
everybody an A in my classes I don't
give everybody an F and I don't give
everybody a C as a matter of fact I
don't even grade on a curve because I
think that curves are kind of unfair you
know saying well there's this big you
know everybody should be more or less in
the middle getting a C except for the
really smart kids who really work hard
and they'll get an A and the really dumb
kids are the ones who don't work hard
they'll get an F and then they'll be you
know somewhat larger group they get a D
and somewhat larger group that can it be
I actually base it I think that's kind
of unfair I actually base
on what a person does so that's
proportioning that little portion of
happiness grades to merit what it is
that they have done through their
performance now justice may also involve
preventing an unfair distribution or
correcting an unfair distribution as
well so he you know he says that at a
different point in their but it's
important to bring that up because
sometimes justice means restoring a
balance that has been lost or disrupted
sometimes deliberately by people
sometimes just over time you know and
for example it could be a very concrete
example of this a lot of people complain
about the rise in college tuition
colleges become so much more expensive
and they start looking for well who's
who's responsible for that and this is a
really big problem well it's not that
they're paying professors more it's not
that particular part of the payroll in
academic affairs because a lot of
schools have shifted away from full-time
you know tenure track professor to
hiring more adjuncts which is very cheap
as a matter of fact they've gotten
themselves in some deep financial
trouble that's gonna be hard to get out
of that way instead what they spent the
money on was high high paid
administrators and lots and lots of
staff you know particularly in student
life and things like that and some on
technology legitimate expense there I
think and a lot I'm gusting up the dorms
and gyms and campuses and cafeterias and
even the classrooms so that they could
you know compete with other schools that
are also doing the same thing that's
where the bulk of the money has gone to
and so if we wanted to talk in terms of
fairness and we asked well who's
actually doing the educating is it the
administrators not really is it the
staff well they play a vital support
role but not really they're not really
educating is it the building's
themselves that all this money's been
pumped into and can't
gotten out of unfortunately that's not
doing any educating the technology is a
good tool we can say that you know
making smart classrooms having you know
course learning sites that sort of thing
that that's kind of handy but you don't
have to give every single student and an
iPad for example what you really need
for education to take place is competent
teachers and students who are ready to
learn and some sort of structure so it
seems fair that the the you know more of
the tuition money should probably go to
faculty development improving the
condition of faculty members faculty
research things like that now you know
it also be fair to say look if we're
going to give you money for that it
better pay off in you know actual
learning for your students but I don't
think that's particularly odorous are
difficult to demonstrate that would be
opposed to say let's hire another VP of
this or we need you know twenty more
staff to do this you know early early
warning initiative or something along
those lines or let's build a new annex
to the gym that would be a bit unfair to
the students to the university community
to the green of public we could explore
lots and lots of issues this way one of
the other things that I want to bring up
is Ross explicitly says not only is it
about distribution of happiness as such
may be a pleasure of virtue intellectual
development
but the means to happiness so what are
the means to happiness wealth is one of
them Ross would say that we actually
have a duty to bring about an equitable
proportionate distribution of wealth in
proportion to merit or if we happen to
inhabit a culture and institution in
which things have gotten unbalanced as
they have in many places then we have
duties
correct that to prevent it from getting
worse if people propose things that are
going to be more on equitable then we
have a duty to prevent that Ross with
saying what are other possibilities
besides wealth opportunity does
everybody have the same opportunities or
at least proportionate opportunities you
know what might we proportion what might
count is merit in this case applying
yourself and demonstrating interest it
could be that we we say not everybody
gets to go to professional school
because not everybody can actually pass
the test scores but if your marginal and
you belong to groups that have been
historically left out maybe there is a
case for helping you in but then you
also say well what about those other
other marginal students who aren't so
privileged as to have the right you know
race gender ethnicity some cases
religion that sort of thing do they get
are they being you know shafted in that
case it's a good question
this this points to the difficulty of
proportioning things is very important
Ross doesn't spell this out in this
chapter but it's very important to think
about what the criteria are for
determining what counts as merit what
we're going to proportion the
distribution of happiness or the means
to happiness to in addition to you know
wealth and opportunities we could also
think of positions of responsibility we
could think of titles we could think
about things that I've brought up
already like time and attention all of
these can be manners for prima-facie
duties to bring about a just state to
maintain
adjust state to prevent unjust states or
to correct unjust states